kris: Hello! My name is Christopher, and you see, my, we just computed we
kris: to check this.
kris: Hello. So the test, you know today is for you to and look like a desk
so.
kris: and i'm going to just screw them
kris: and search for the both. My. so i'm.
Thanks.
kris: I'm straight now you so i'm going to
It's it's it's clear in the
kris: sure i'm taking. So in it they take any way of saying
so. I'm just checking if I did miss it
kris: if he
Okay.
kris: I i'm the screen.
Thank you for the book by button.
kris: No.
kris: let's see.
kris: Okay. yeah. I see you. So right now i'm going to create an activity move to my.
kris: So let's see. I I personally think that the is too far down personally. so I
fine evening
kris: so. But I mean, I think he was. He was very simple enough.
kris: Okay.
both
sorry for the past.
So ring, though
kris: I I know i'm going to click again to remove the activity
kris: for the moment. And
kris: so, in in my opinion, I
kris: is too far down
so because that has to screw that out.
kris: But
kris: and after you're reading everything, so it just makes it.
kris: I I went to the bottom. but maybe you can. I don't. They work at the top.
and it's having the pay. So you have to
kris: everything down to search for the button.
kris: I think if everything looks good and it's seem pretty off.
kris: and it's usable.